all right sasha yes sasha where'd you
grow up where are you from originally um
i grew up in the valley um born in
silmar
um
my mom
my dad supposed to be a one-night stand
kind of thing dad didn't try to do the
right thing by marrying her you know
mom didn't want to get married
dad went to prison for the first year of
my life
i got out of prison
came to the house where my mom was
staying at
mom wasn't even there she was upstairs
at a friend's house i was in the kitchen
crying
and my dad said that he walked into the
kitchen and i walked over to him and i
stopped crying and i called him dad and
he said from that one he knew that i was
his daughter and he would do everything
in his power to get me to be with him so
um
about a year or two forward my mom calls
and says hey i need you to watch her
i'm gonna go shopping my dad says please
make sure you come and get her because i
start my new job's wrong
my mom said sure of course i got it
sure enough she didn't come back for a
whole week and when she finally called
my dad said look just pack up her stuff
she's gonna come stay with me
and my mom's like no and my dad's like
well if you fight me you know
you know where it's gonna go so you know
my mom didn't fight and my dad took me
and uh
i saw my mom off and on until i was
about
six
and uh my mom attempted to kidnap me and
she was gonna take me to puerto rico
under the pretense that supposedly i
called her saying that somebody was
touching me
and which i don't recall any of that but
you know um
she was a whole big scheme you know my
her husband at the time ended up jumping
my dad with some friends and they
stabbed him and
cops got involved they took off and i
didn't see them for eight years
um so my dad raised me um and he was
like he's been my best friend
you know my whole life
i myself was just a very unique child
with a lot of unique uh
abilities and uh
gifts you could say um i just i was
different and
so going to school
i
just i i
i don't know i i couldn't stand
uh being um
being next to people who didn't know the
right answer or you know um
knowing that they didn't know the right
answer and still got picked and i didn't
get picked to say the answer you know i
think you knew the answer it just
bothered me so i
just started to do other things in
school you know um i
basically completely went 360
became a satanist
i
got bumped up in the eighth grade to
ninth grade and from then on it's when i
started using drugs
i met my boyfriend at the time noel
he was
18. i was
uh what 14
15 years old and um yeah uh
it was on a kraken from then um i
started using methamphetamine
um
and then come to find out you know i had
this like routine i would always do i'd
go through my dad's stuff since i was a
kid it was just something i did and uh
that was the cool [ __ ]
and so one day i was going through one
of my routines going through his truck
and i found this huge bag
which looked like what i had just tried
you know and it was full of it how like
there's no way so i went to my dad and i
said dad um you heard about this thing
called mess
and i was like oh you know where where
did you try that like so you better tell
me if you did you know i'm like no no i
just my friends were talking about in
school of course i was lying you know
and a couple months later i finally
confessed to my dad that yeah i had
tried math and
i
always had this thing where like i would
make my dad feel guilty about certain
things in order to
get him to do things that
i wanted you know so i was like well you
know if you're smoking a two dad like we
should just smoke it together why not
you know he's like no are you crazy and
i'm like well i guess i'm gonna go out
there and smoke with my friends and get
raped and probably killed you know and
of course putting my dad in this weird
guilt trip my dad's like okay here you
know like just smoking here at home like
don't don't go out there and do it like
that
and
i convinced my dad to let me smoke mess
with him and uh
so from then on
i started uh using heroin i had a
boyfriend at the time he was
uh an adult you know i was a minor and
he introduced me to heroin he gave me a
fat shot of heroin
and i od'd the first time i did it i
didn't really like it
um i tried again three months later just
because he was doing it and i started
doing it every day i started using
cocaine and heroin
and that was my that was my love that
was my
it felt so good and and i
definitely confused love with with
with the comfort of that you know thing
that i loved to this person until this
person went to jail and i was on my own
and i
didn't shoot myself up so now i had to
shoot myself up for the first time and
called connect for my first time by
myself
and uh
i got a hold of danny or daddy got a
hold of me from jail and uh
he told me here's the number the
connection like go get well and whatever
and i met with him and
i realized i didn't love danny i didn't
need danny i needed danny to shoot me up
i needed him to to make sure that i was
high and i didn't need him anymore for
that so
i realized that uh i didn't i never i
didn't love him you know so uh i started
using heroin uh regularly um
i went to miami
for the second time uh
seeing my mom uh i hadn't seen her in
eight years the first time prior to me
went out there this is the second time a
couple years later so it was about 10
years um i went out there to change my
life i was like you know what i'm i'm
tired of this dad like like we can't
keep doing this together like we got it
we got to get better both of us you know
by this point i would had already became
award of the court and i was constantly
running away from group homes and
everything going back to my dad and
running amok
and uh i wanted to do it right because i
wanted to be with my dad you know my dad
was everything to me you know and i
loved him so much i mean i still love
him so much you know i just i want to do
the right thing by him and so i went out
there
i got clean i was like i was about 16
and a half years old
and i started doing amateur bodybuilding
and i trained for the whole time i was
out there and it was awesome you know i
got my first real job
um i had a little apartment with my
brother um my older brother which is my
mom's son and uh we have different dads
um it was awesome and
i started um
acting up a little bit out there
and
i
basically got into a fight with my
brother and i ended up moving out and
getting a place i'm moving in with a
friend of mine and uh
my dad didn't answer the phone for one
two three days
and i
i knew by this by the third day that he
was probably in prison or probably in
jail because my dad never not answered
more than two days
and uh finally about a week later i get
a phone call from jail
telling me what happened and
i was just i was devastated it it rocked
my whole world you know and i i was like
how am i gonna get back to california
you know my mom's gonna pay for me to
get back out there she doesn't want me
to go out there
so um realizing that i was still awarded
the court
i
ended up getting a fight with my brother
and the cops were called and i told them
and they had dcfs fly out from
california come get me
so i ended up back in california
and i'm i'm still still trying to do the
right thing
um i'm trying to get a job and i'm
trying to
you know do accordingly as dcfs wants me
to so i can go to my dad's court
hearings and stuff like that and try to
get him out
and so a friend of my dad's who was his
customers ex-customers
they were no longer using and they said
hey
we'll tell dc best you can come stay
with us
all right cool
i find that i'm pregnant i'm not
pregnant the last day
that i before i lived florida
and i was pregnant with my son
and i wasn't going to keep him
um i
definitely wasn't ready for a child and
i even if i got clean it it still didn't
make me ready to be a parent
my aunt got one to this my mom's sister
and said you know hey uh i got remarried
and i i wanted to adopt a child because
i can't have kids anymore it's already
blood let me adopt it i said sure you
know what why it's it's not his fault he
didn't have to be brought into the world
and i was kind of like a surrogate for
her so i um
i got stayed through the pregnancy and i
stayed clean until about my eighth month
i relapsed
um
thinking back on it now i think that i
did it to disconnect from the child
because i didn't want
you know when he was born yes i i had a
i had a
love for him i didn't i didn't i wasn't
going to be his mom you know and i
didn't want to also go oh you know what
i changed my mind i don't want to you
know do this and
you know ruin this child's life
so i i think that's why i didn't you
know i i reconnected with danny
the guy who got me on heroin and uh i
showed up at the park to meet him and he
knows i'm pregnant and i'm he has a
syringe full of dope for me ready to
shoot me up in the bathroom and it's
what he did
and uh
we had this whole little fantasy in her
head like i let him believe you know
that he was
going to be the the father to this child
and he let him name it and
you know just i don't know what i was
thinking it was just ridiculous child
[ __ ] but um
yeah so when my son was born uh i told
that myself i said hey i've used heroin
um and he's probably gonna be sick and i
want to make sure he gets the medical
attention he needs
he came out um a little addicted heroin
uh didn't withdraw much
he was very healthy very healthy baby
beautiful uh
all the nurses wanted to be on shift to
deal with him you know
um but yeah i uh
my aunt came into her got him and
so on so forth and she wanted to give me
an opportunity to be a mom to him
and i i
i still didn't want to you know um but i
didn't want to get clean because i still
want to do right by my dad
and so i put myself in rehab i got
myself a cry help nobody made me do it
no nobody funded it for me i put myself
there um
besides a little backup from dcfs having
some kind of support because that was
already 18. you know that was about it
so um in the midst of me being there you
know i uh
i relapsed once they let me back in and
uh
my aunt brought my son down there and
said hey if you want opportunity to be a
mom i'm giving you an opportunity you
have a chance you know because i i don't
i don't want to be the one to not give
you that chance and i was like thank you
i appreciate that you know and
for a couple months i thought about it
and and i saw him a couple times you
know stayed clean
but i
that was her son you know and i had that
in my head already that was her child
and i wanted him to have a good life and
i know that she could get with him
so i um i ended up leaving cry help and
um
i stayed clean i stayed i stayed clean
for several years and i i
i got a job and i um i got my own place
i had another child i had my daughter
isabella lose bell but
um
and that was that was the love of my
life like i loved her i loved her so
much you know
she was everything to me um she was born
blind um i
i was already a year clean when i got
pregnant with her um just she had
congenital glaucoma
so i am i did everything i i threw
myself into her you know i i
put her in school since she was two
months she was in the blind children's
center in the brett institute i did
pivot you know because dc was trying to
get involved in my life because i had a
blind child whatever you know so i did
whatever i had to do to make sure that
they knew that i was doing everything
that i was supposed to do
and um
the person i was with that i had the
child with was
the epitome of a
a satanist that gives a sickness a bad
name and what i mean by that is when
people think oh satan has sacrificed
kids and they worship you know a
demons in the ground and
that's the kind of person he was you
know he
you couldn't even sing a song around him
that you see stairway to heaven he's
like don't sing that song and said
heaven
kind of ridiculous [ __ ] you know what i
mean but from great evil came great
beauty my daughter was born with the
third eye like you wouldn't believe and
she gave me sight she gave me foolsight
and my daughter just everything she
touches is is gold um
you know um
by
by no fault of my own i i
there was a feud going on between my
neighbor
and my uh
daughter's dad's parents and they called
the cops on us or on them not on us and
they came out there and they said my
daughter was like [ __ ] like she
couldn't do anything for herself and uh
they came out there and inspected my
daughter and everything was fine and it
makes sense to them so they didn't
bother me months or two passed and all
of a sudden i get a phone call and
they're like hey we want you to come in
just to make sure everything's cool sure
why not you should get letters of
recommendations from you know whoever
you can okay cool got letters
recommendations from our doctors or
teachers
people who wouldn't put their jobs on
jeopardy just to lie and say i'm a good
parent you know
and uh
i went out i i had an appointment i
didn't have
all my letters i didn't have the one
from her doctor and so i
um
i missed my appointment by one day i
went in the next day voluntarily and i
bought the paperwork with me
and uh they
each picked up us
the stack of papers didn't even even
read them just sat back on the table and
said well we fill that uh
you're uh
you're not you still feel like you're
able to take your child with you today
so you're gonna have to uh surrender
your child here and i just look at them
like what are you kidding me like what
are you talking about am i gonna send to
my child and they tricked me into coming
in and i had to surrender my child
and then i relapse
and um
you know you do things a certain way
and you
you expect people to respect that you
expect people to see that and you expect
people to
to abide by some kind of standard or
rule that as humans
you think that we all have you know
and uh it doesn't work like that it
doesn't work like that at all and it's
it's [ __ ] ruthless
and uh
so i uh
i had a little falling down you know i
plunged into [ __ ] heroin and cocaine
and um then i pulled my head out of my
ass and i said what am i doing i started
doing exactly what they want me to do
so i i got with it i got with the
program
and for a whole year i [ __ ] busted my
ass i i did everything and more that
they wanted me to do separated from her
dad got another place i i did all the
programs and some
and uh but it's funny because the the da
that was a da when me and my dad were in
dcfs was the same da that was my da now
for me and my daughter same judge
everything and they hated me my dad
so when the d.a
finally said i have nothing to say
against her the judge said i have
nothing yet to say against her i was
like what
you're like yeah she's doing everything
she's supposed to do now it's up to dcfs
to start the reunification
i was like whoa i was like really i was
like
i was so proud of myself you know
so when my worker told me that they
couldn't start
that she didn't feel that uh we could
start doing uh unwanted visits because
she felt i was in contact with the
father still
i was like it it was like a gunshot to
my head you know i just what are you
kidding me like did you not hear the
judge in the d.a
and i didn't i didn't if i knew
then what i know now
i i would have never stopped hiding
but i thought that it was hopeless i
thought that they were going to do
everything in their power to make sure
that i didn't and which they still would
have but
at that point if i was just hung in
there i would have got her back for sure
but i gave up i got weak and um
i drowned myself in a jump scan and i've
been on not run ever since
it's the longest one i've ever been on
um i called up my mom one day
the woman who left me and i said uh mom
i need you to come and get my daughter
click
that was it
i didn't think anything would come of it
a month later my mom was down here every
court date flying from miami until she
got my daughter
and the day that they were flying back
together i
met them at the station at the airport
and how was she beautiful
she was gorgeous uh
she looked at me with those blue eyes
you know because just because she can't
see the way we can see to me she can't
see
and she said mom
she said i know you do these things that
i don't really like and they keep you
away from me she goes but it's okay she
goes i know
i know that
that you'll get better and then you'll
be with me again and she goes man i'm
not mad at you
she said i just want you to get better
because i love you
and they were gone
and uh
you know uh
at first i was
i was jealous of my own child i didn't
understand
why she got to help my mom and i didn't
you know i
i didn't get it you know and and
finally i realized that i sacrificed
having a mom all these years so she
could have a mom for
what she was headed for because
my daughter is an amazing child
she uh is 14 years old now
she plays the violin the cello the
ukulele
the piano the guitar
she goes to school in colorado for the
blind and deaf
she actually just um
actually just released the newest tour
um you're looking online and it's uh
uh
for the blind kids on the she's giving
the tour of the school
and um
she has access to everything you know
anything she could possibly need or want
or
i mean if these kids
had any any hindrance of any kind it's
no longer there because
they're they're able to to soar and and
and and flourish and just grow it's
amazing this place
and so basically where i left off my mom
picked up and did what i hoped she would
have done
um my mom eventually changed her life in
her 30s
she became accountant for a new world
symphony
my mom going from being a working at
like oppa and being you know kind of
like a club rat you know uh
to that you know i just
i was like wow that's pretty amazing you
know and uh
she has her own little business she she
has a restaurant she's a great cook
and they she greased people at the door
with a glass of wine and you know the
high-end restaurant you know and
i mean she's just doing the thing you
know
and she has given my daughter every
opportunity in the world for whatever
she wants to do she ski she's adaptive
skiing adopted bowling after soccer she
right she rides bikes she plays baseball
she um
she does rock climbing
wanted sky's this girl you know
and uh
i would have fought and did everything i
could but i don't know if i could have
given the same opportunities you know
not saying that i i i couldn't have but
i don't know you know and i would have
liked to think that i could have but
you know
the fact that my mom is and the fact
that she's throwing everything that she
has into my daughter
makes me think that
you know she's making up for lost time
with me you know and and i appreciate
that i think you've forgiven your mom i
have i have and if i can become
have the woman that my mom is now
a pretty great woman
because um she's
she's a broken awesome woman and i just
want her to know that i'm so grateful
for her
i'm
so grateful for what she said for my
daughter
i'm grateful for what my aunt's done for
my son
because my son is the same thing he's
flourished in life and he's
he does all kinds of things and he's
smart and [ __ ]
and they're just they're just amazing
kids and they've had amazing parents
so i thank them
um
i got it to a point in my life where i
just
i was probably the lowest i've ever been
um
you know i've always made sure that
if i had a habit i supported it you know
like i i
i'm not one of those people who just be
out there like begging for stuff or you
know not making sure that if i want to
do it i want to make sure i have what i
want because i want to do it you know
so uh
i pretty make sure that i've always like
slained or you know things like that um
i i was pretty much homeless with my dad
the whole time my dad pretty much
followed me to the streets when he got
out of prison um
yes he couldn't he felt so guilty for
leaving me you know that he felt like he
had to do this because he couldn't um
he he had to make up for lost time
so he followed me and uh
i basically always had at least my dad
you know and uh
so because he felt so guilty he made
sure that if i could provide something
for myself that he found a way to do it
and so it was always been my dad out
there you know and i always had that
extra backup which i was very grateful
for because if i didn't i don't know if
i would have made it
um looking back now i don't think i
would have
because i got myself into some hairy
situations you know and my dad being the
respectable man that he is and
integrity that he has and uh
you know there's plenty of times where
just my dad
knowing that that's my dad and you know
got me out of a lot of things
um
so when coleman hit you know for a lot
of people that was devastating you know
but for me it was
a golden opportunity it was beautiful
because i got a chance that i probably
would have never gotten a chance
ever in life you know like
every excuse i ever had was basically
abolished it was it
everything was brought to me you know
they brought the dmv to my freaking uh
hotel door said here stand right here in
front of the screen take a picture while
sending your id in the mail
but you know just everything that i
didn't have they brought it to me and i
had
and
from 2000 uh 2018 i've been in the
airtel sportsman's
um
studio six you know i've been basically
living in hotels for free
until now where i finally got an
apartment
and um
man
so you're you're homeless for a while oh
for a long time
since uh
since i lost my daughter basically you
know i mean it's a long time you know
intense
uh maybe you guys have been intense
living without a tent let me know on the
side of the freeway you know watching
people die being hit by trains uh
disappear
um
i mean suicide uh
murder you know
things that you're not supposed to talk
about you know and it's probably as much
as i can say you know but
it's crazy because
there's a whole other world out there
right down the street from everyone's
house and most people have no clue
no clue um
it's so crazy that
you know
what everyone considers norm
everyone takes for granted
going to store brushing their teeth
um getting dressed
becomes fearful you know you become
fearful of those things walking to the
corner to burger king to get something
because
you're so afraid of seeing somebody you
know from your past or
or being looked at a certain way or or
just in general like
it's almost like some kind of like
phobia you know
i remember one time i leave the trail on
moscow dakota
for two weeks and i thought about like
that was the last time i left the trail
he's like i don't know maybe like
i don't think i've seen you leave here
like in at least a week and i was like
are you serious and he's like yeah
i remember once in a shower for 32 days
i mean i burned fast every day you know
like i normally did but take a legit
shower for 32 days i didn't shower for
32 days who the [ __ ] just had you know
me
and it's so it flies by so fast
so fast
and you're just like what the [ __ ]
but it's crazy time their time is
irrelevant you know
back there for sure you know if there
was ever an idea time does not exist
back there if you're living that life
for a while do you get does it become
normalized
it does it does it i'm not taking a
shower or not all that it it
it becomes so normal that
like i said you become fearful of the
outside world you know i mean like and
when people are bringing you um
food
and stuff like that and it's making it
to where you don't have to leave that
little comfort of behind the trail where
no one can see you and you're kind of
just
invisible to everybody so you still you
think um
you know you definitely you get
comfortable really quick and
you lose track of time and everything
and it becomes it becomes the idea of
like
oh so much time has gone by how am i
going to ever get back into society so i
can let me back in they're going to make
it so hard for me how am i going to do
that like
it's crazy you know like how many
success stories do you know you know you
start thinking about you're like [ __ ]
already you know
and
so when they came
to the back of a denny's on uh burbank
and spoda
i said yeah me take me
and um
they did and i i went and i and i i was
terrified it was crazy it was so funny
because it was like did it take you to
get housing yeah well they took me they
took me to the airtel
and uh here i am in this nice hotel and
i can't stop and sit still like i'm
ready okay i'm ready to go let's go
outside and go play now you know and i'm
like i found myself leaving every every
couple hours and i'm like what what am i
doing you know
it was so hard to adjust
it was so hard to get used to just
staying in that room
that was comfortable and ac and shower
and and tv and and i still barely watch
tv anymore like
because it's so surreal to me and it's
it seems like such [ __ ]
you know and i just like it it's so sad
you know that one good thing about
losing all that time is
not being a part of all that you know
and not seeing all that and it's like
it it you don't get caught up in it so
easily because i get i see it on tv and
i'm just like
click you know i'm not all like oh god
we're we're going to war russia so this
and that and
you're like okay i gotta go you know it
doesn't
it doesn't phase you like that anymore
at least not for me you know and i'm
that i'm actually truly grateful for
because
i don't think i had a lot of stress
but um you know i
you
having my daughter definitely gave me a
different sight that i i don't think i
would have ever had in life if i didn't
have her um
[Music]
this site to me is debilitating it gets
a crutch it's a crutch for us to make
excuses across to us for to
um
to rat to
to just justify things you know that
shouldn't be justified you know um
you know i see everything for what it is
you know and and i
i take the time to appreciate that you
know
sometimes you run into somebody and you
have a five-minute conversation with
them that's just as valuable as somebody
you've known your whole life and you
will take it with you everywhere you go
and you'll have a love for that person
or an understanding for that person that
is amazing it'll be an honor to have met
that person you know in honor to
establish a moment in their life you
know and i've been able to capture that
i've been able to capture a pocket of
time
and um
i know what love is i know what it is to
give and receive love i've
you know i i've experienced some amazing
people in my life
and that i'm so grateful for it i don't
know if i would have taken the time to
to stop and talk to certain people if i
wouldn't have gone through what i've
gone through
because um
i never did before you know i was always
the badass you know the crazy crazy
[ __ ] you know like [ __ ] no one's
[ __ ] me my name echoed you know i
mean [ __ ] 10 years oh sasha i know
that girl like
and that that was cool i was a
legitimate mind i was happy with that
you know but
you know i i
there's some people
people don't realize that this
does not discriminate
you know um
chris cornell
uh the barges you know people out here
that um
you would never you would never guess
but they're my neighbors you know they
were my neighbors at one point on the
streets like you know i mean like it
doesn't discriminate it doesn't it
doesn't pick and choose i i have friends
that are doctors friends are lawyers
friends that were teachers friends that
were in in the bosnian war friends that
were
a shield ballet instructor uh in paris
um i have friends that traveled the
whole world and had careers like you
wouldn't imagine who made a billion
dollars and lost it already
maybe sometimes you get a point in your
life where you just go so high up that
there's nowhere else to go down i don't
know you know um why people make
decisions they make but they make them
and for whatever reason they end up in
these spots and they're forgotten about
and it's [ __ ] tragic
something tragic because
nobody deserves to be forgotten
and i and i try my best not to forget
you know i i try not to do well
or or hang uh
you know uh
hey with a chip on my shoulder you know
i tend to justify everyone else's
actions but my own you know because my
dad's always held me to a certain
standard so i tried to help myself to
that as well um
but yeah i
i always think you know
what it took to get that person to where
they are now you know what did they go
through what what had to happen
you know who am i
you know who is who is some
some religious figure to judge somebody
who is you know like who who are we to
do that and i don't think any of us have
that right to do that
i think that we
as humans uh lost a trait a long time
ago
which was
something that were born with some kind
of
human understanding of uh
acknowledgement to acknowledge somebody
you know um
excuse me ma'am your skirt stuck in your
in your in your pants or uh you know you
got some of your teeth or just hello how
are you doing
simple hello
how are you good day you know just
acknowledgement
in a world this big you should not feel
alone
and there's been times where i feel like
i'm screaming on top of my lungs and
nobody can hear me
and i feel so alone
and that's crazy to me because there's
so many people you know how could you
feel alone but i do and i did um i i
don't so much now but i did that and
um
it just it
because acknowledgement you know we have
a there's a a a universal language
we don't know how to speak we can
gestures
how are you
you know by you know uh
thank you you know
you'll have to be the same let me should
know what somebody's saying or give me a
gesture of you know
and if we can't even give somebody their
simple born
even right as a human of acknowledgement
where have we gotten in life you know i
think about that like
have we in my eyes i feel like we have d
evolved in so many ways
you know our our senses are are
are are are completely um interrupted by
all this
[ __ ] you know we a sense of touch
and and smell and
and laughter you know nobody writes
notes to each other anymore nobody
nobody blows a kiss anymore anyone holds
hands anymore
and that's sad that's really sad and i
and i when i see it i try to hold on to
it because i think it's beautiful
you know because that's that's what my
daughter taught me you know the beauty
and all that
and because she doesn't have time for
the [ __ ] she doesn't she's picks a
flower and she doesn't see dying petals
she sees a flower what it is
and and then
that's pretty awesome you know so
i i try to
think that um i look up to my daughter
and she's my hero you know
and uh i can't wait to meet with her
again
and i hope that she's about me
the way i'm about of her
and i hope that my dad
has forgiven me
i hope that he's proud of me
i see him all the time you know but
you know i still
wonder
behind that smile you know
i've hurt a lot of people
a lot of people have hurt me
and i hope to
get back
let me tell you that time is the most
unforgiving thing
you can't get back last time people move
on and they go on without you
but
time can also be very healing and um
i really hope that um
people
that i've
hurt or
that i've wronged in a way but they
didn't deserve it
understand that
it wasn't me you know that
you're you go into this uh
self-preserved mode and you kind of go
into autopilot
and uh
so things i said that i might not have
met or
things that i did that
i probably would have never actually
done you know if i would have
been in my right state of mind
i hope that they can understand that you
know everyone makes mistakes we're not
perfect
in any way shape or form
perfection is a
is a
a long shout out you know uh
goal of people but
perfection to me
you know
somebody once told me sasha the more you
hurt yourself the more beautiful you
look to me you're like cosplaying he
says
it doesn't faze me you know he goes
everything tells a story about you you
know everything the way you move the way
you walk
the marks on your body
yours and i see past all that because i
see you for you
you and you can't you can't
this doesn't work on me you know so
you know you just
just know that
this sort of idea of perfection is
something that's not um
it's something that that
that we all created you know that the
world is created for to have some kind
of uh
crutch for what you know what should be
you know but
there's beauty all around us and it
comes in every shape and form and
you know i i don't mind now
you know who i am and
i'm i'm okay with me you know and i know
what i do what i don't do i know what i
say what i don't say and no one can tell
me otherwise
i'm i'm that's one thing i'm very
grateful for that that all this has
given me is
the sense of me
and me is awesome
you know sasha thank you so much for
sharing your story
thank you very much you're welcome
you